nous entendons cet après-midi monsieur
Christophe de Loire secrétaire général
de Reporters sans frontières vous avez
exercé monsieur Deloire des fonctions
dans divers médias comme Arte ou le
point vous avez été directeur et
vice-président du Centre de Formation
des Journalistes de 2008 à 2012 et vous
êtes devenu en juillet 2012 secrétaire
général de reporter sans frontière pour
rappel reporter son frontière est une
organisation non gouvernementale
internationale fondée en 85 reconnu
d'utilités publiques en France présente
en 2020 en 14 pays qui se donnent
notamment pour objectif la défense de la
liberté de la presse et la protection
des sources des journalistes en mars
2021 RSF a déposé plainte contre
Facebook aux motif que le réseau social
ça donne nouvelle légumes à des
pratiques commerciales trompeuses fermer
les guillemets dans la mesure où la
prolifération de messages haineux où les
fausses informations reliées sur la
plateforme violent selon vous les
engagements de facebook vis-à-vis de ses
utilisateurs
plus généralement vous avez développé un
ensemble de recommandations à la fois
juridique et pratique destinés à rendre
le fonctionnement des plateformes plus
conformes au grand principe qui doivent
encadrer l'information dans une société
démocratique et à lutter contre la
désinformation ce sont des sujets qu'on
a déjà eu l'occasion de traiter dans le
cadre de la commission mais je pense
qu'il est intéressant de voir votre
votre expertise sur le sujet votre point
de vue vous pourrez nous dire si c'est
recommandations s'appliquent à Tik Tok
et de quelle manière je rappelle que
l'audition est captée retransmise en
direct sur le site du Sénat et avant de
vous laisser la parole je dois procéder
au formalités d'usage pour les
commissions d'enquête
vous essayez de me censurer
c'est de la censure je vais hurler au
sabotage
donc je dois vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage justement devant notre
commission d'enquête et passible des
peines priveuses archives 434 13 434 et
434 15 du code pénal et je vous invite à
prêter serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité en levant la main
droite et en disant je le jure
on vous écoute pour un propos liminaire
peut-être justement sur sur le cœur du
sujet que nous venons d'évoquer sur les
informations que vous souhaiteriez nous
donner et puis ce qui serait intéressant
c'est que vous puissiez interagir avec
les commissaires à commencer par
monsieur le rapporteur
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
pour votre
présentation j'apporterai
un tout petit complément pour dire
douche parle le mandat de Reporters sans
frontières c'est de défendre le
journaliste le journalisme étant entendu
comme un ensemble de droits et de
devoirs et les uns et les autres étant
également important la vision de notre
organisation étant que les faire en
sorte que les êtres humains puissent
bénéficier autant que possible
d'informations fiables leur permettant
de faire des choix individuels ou
collectifs
la Chine est d'ailleurs évidemment un
pays extrêmement important pour notre
organisation elle est aujourd'hui
classée à l'avant-dernière place du
classement mondial de la liberté de la
presse la 179e sur 180 pays
il y a que la Corée du Nord derrière
enfin ça dépend de l'endroit où on se
trouve
plus de 100 journalistes ils sont
incarcérés à l'heure actuelle et encore
cette statistique ne rend pas totalement
compte
de l'intensité de la répression du
système de répression et du système de
propagande mise en place en Chine
ainsi désormais qu'à Hong Kong ou le
seul
grand patron de la presse indépendante
qui demeurait Jimmy li malgré son grand
âge a été placé en détention c'est un
pays sur lequel nous avons publié
plusieurs rapports j'en citerai deux en
2021 le grand bon en arrière des médias
très clairement
la Chine est un pays qui durcit son
système de répression qu'il a fait
depuis l'accession pouvoir de site
Jinping par rapport à la période
précédente du président rodintao
et nous avions publié préalablement 2019
un rapport intitulé Le Nouvel Ordre
Mondial des médias selon Pékin Pékin est
un régime qui non content de réprimer le
journaliste plus linge plus largement
l'information indépendante en tant
changer l'ordre mondial de l'information
et s'il y a donne par des moyens divers
et variés qui vont d'une opération
tapis rouge bien nommée consistant à
inviter des journalistes étrangers pour
leur apprendre le journaliste au
caractéristique chinoises à des méthodes
relevant plus de la diplomatie et de
l'influence dans les organisations
internationales en charge de ces
questions
j'ai commencé mon intervention en
tentant de répondre rapidement à deux
questions qu'est-ce qu'une plateforme
numérique et deuxièmement qu'est-ce que
Tik Tok pour nous
vous à ce stade vous connaissez myotype
que je ne le fais donc je vais plutôt
entrer dans des questions plus générales
et notamment sur des logiques de
régulation de notre point de vue très
clairement une plateforme numérique
n'est ni un hébergeur ni un éditeur il
s'agit peu à peu de distinguer un
troisième statut
on ne saurait parler d'un hébergeur dès
lors que le travail d'une société comme
Tik Tok n'est pas neutre que les
algorithmes de curation et de
recommandations organisent ce qu'on voit
ce qu'on voit moins et ce qu'on ne voit
pas du tout
mais il s'agit pas non plus d'un média
puisqu'il ne produit pas le contenu ont
une taille qui dépasse largement la
taille des médias bref de notre point de
vue ces entités structurantes organisent
l'espace public
ça n'est peut-être pas le lieu pour le
dire mais d'une certaine manière les
grandes plateformes numériques ont
remplacé le Parlement kodizlo le code
c'est la loi sedicte les règles des lois
qui autrefois étaient adoptées par le
Parlement l'équivalent des lois sur la
distribution de l'information elle
remplace la justice puisque
elles appliquent leurs propres règles
elles remplacent les administrations
puisque certaines d'entre elles allaient
des fonds y compris aux médias mais à
leur manière toute discrétionnaire et
sont considération pour des principes
démocratiquement admis
plus que cela elles exercent à un
ministère de la Vérité
le elles exercent un ministère de la
vérité puisque les plateformes ont
encore la possibilité de prendre des
décisions sur
des aspects éditoriaux c'est Facebook
qui a décidé pendant longtemps que le
virus n'était pas sorti des laboratoires
de one je précise que je ne sais pas
d'où est sorti le virus mais que
facebook le savait et l'avait imposé à
ses algorithmes
Tik Tok comme des révélations du gardien
en 2019 ont permis de l'établir
interdisaient qu'il soit question de
certains faits pourtant historiquement
avéré c'est exactement ce qu'on appelle
un ministère de la Vérité notre point de
vue c'est que les plateformes numériques
devraient être au fond considéré comme
des services d'intérêt général des
publics utilities
elle devrait être traitée d'une certaine
manière comme des délégataires de
services publics et des obligations de
l'oeuvre vraie leur être imposée comme à
tout délégataire de service public la
question évidemment à chaque fois c'est
quelle responsabilité
de notre point de vue la législation
européenne déjà adoptée ou en cours n'a
pas réponse à tout
qu'est-ce que Tik Tok rapidement TikTok
c'était évidemment un enjeu ou un danger
pour la démocratie un service privé pour
créer des influenceurs et les pousser à
la consommation
je ne prendrai qu'un exemple récent il
semble que Tik Tok a laissé diffuser des
contenus sponsorisés des publicités
politiques pour des marques de
trottinettes en libre-service
dans lesquels des créateurs de contenus
appelés à se mobiliser à voter contre
l'interdiction des trottinettes en
libre-service à Paris alors c'était
peut-être pas le plus grand exercice
démocratique qui soit mais ça montre
qu'une entité comme TikTok peut faire et
qu'elle rôle elle peut jouer c'est un
enjeu pour les libertés publiques je
renvoie toutes les questions qui ont
déjà été évoquées de vente votre
Commission en matière de surveillance
c'est un enjeu pour les médias en termes
de
marcher et d'audience avec
l'observer évidemment des médias qui
pour pouvoir aller chercher une audience
ou s'adresser à une audience jeune vont
sur TikTok c'est un enjeu pour la
liberté de la presse BuzzFeed avait
révélé ce que TikTok a reconnu que des
ingénieurs de sa société mère avaient
accédé à des informations sur des
sources journalistiques en fait avaient
via des enquêtes sur des journalistes
identifiés qu'elles avaient pu être des
sources de contenu c'était en décembre
2002 il faut d'ailleurs reconnaître à
Tik Tok de souvent reconnaître ce qui
s'est passé en disant que c'était
exceptionnel lié à des brebis égarés
[Musique]
bref
en conclusion de ce paragraphe
Tik Tok n'est pas la seule plateforme
qui peut a pu ou peut poser des
questions en matière de surveillance et
Edward Snowden nous en avait
suffisamment appris sur le programme
prisme américain donc qui
convient même si je ne renvoie
évidemment pas de ados Washington et
Pékin
mais de ne pas considérer que le
problème de la surveillance les
plateformes se limite très à TikTok Tik
Tok de PET le paratonnerre qui empêche
de s'intéresser aux autres plateformes
néanmoins il y a des spécificités une
question générale me semble-t-il qui est
posée en matière de
respect de de principe démocratiques et
de conformité des plateformes aux
principes démocratique c'est qu'il y a
la charge de la preuve
est-ce que c'est
aux autorités à la justice d'établir que
des infractions sont commises ou est-ce
que c'est aux plateformes elles-mêmes
d'établir a priori
grâce notamment à dispositif de
transparence mais mais pas seulement
quel respectent des principes
démocratiquement admis
la législation est en cours notamment au
niveau européen le DSA DMA ont un
certain nombre enfin sont des avancées
notables mais souffrent d'un certain
nombre
de fragilité
le dessin porte plutôt sur la modération
que sur les algorithmes de
recommandation qui s'intéressent plutôt
à la distinction entre le chant du lycée
et de l'illicité
plutôt qu'à l'organisation du lycée or
les espaces publics démocratiques ont
toujours été des la construction
démocratique s'est faite sur
l'organisation du chant du lycée et la
promotion de forme d'intégrité dans le
licite par la régulation des médias par
la distinction entre la publicité les
contes du journalistique et le DSA
manifestement ça n'est pas ses points de
force la question des messageries n'y
est pas traité non plus
s'agissant d'un sujet central qui est la
question de la fiabilité de
l'information il y a eu un
enfin ce qui est plus qu'un cas d'école
qui est un test qui est le code de
pratique contre la désinformation de la
Commission européenne un engagement
était attendu des plateformes dans un
texte qu'ils ont le n'est pas hostile au
plateforme qui a été abondamment négocié
avec eux
un engagement 22.6 sur les indicateurs
de fiabilité et le code de pratique
demande au plateforme numérique de
s'engager à proposer à leurs audiences
des indicateurs de fiabilité un
engagement extrêmement faible disons le
ce que nous pensons c'est que la
fiabilité de l'information doit être il
doit en être tenu compte dans
l'indexation algorithmique elle-même
engagement faible attendu néanmoins une
seule plateforme la signer ces Microsoft
et Tik Tok n'a donc pas fait partie des
signataires
ce que quelques mots sur ce que reporter
à sans frontières a lancé comme
initiative et qui peuvent nourrir nous
semble-t-il vos travaux
trois éléments nous avons fourni une
note à l'appui de cette intervention et
mais pour les éclairer un
la régulation suppose
des niveaux de granularité et sont
aujourd'hui portent sur
dans une période de changement de
paradigme sur des enjeux tellement
nouveaux qui convient de l'inventer que
ce soit une régulation caractère
législative ou
d'autres formes de régulation plus
infras et c'est pourquoi nous avons
lancé le partenariat sur l'information
et la démocratie 50 états un organe
d'application d'un formuler des
centaines de recommandations dont
certaines je crois peuvent nourrir votre
commission
et et
que nous tenons à votre disposition dans
plusieurs rapports avec certaines des je
crois des des propositions qui ont été
formées dans des cadres de régulation
sur les messageries privées la
modération la promotion de la fiabilité
de l'information les régimes de
responsabilité des comptes de réseaux
sociaux
la journaliste initiative
fondée sur une norme européenne avec des
audits externes des médias un dispositif
de certification quel en est le sens le
sens c'est de promouvoir la fiabilité de
l'information sans décision
discrétionnelle ni des états ni des
plateformes voyons de grandes avancées
d'abord parce que le Yoro perd
mederfeedom Act actuellement sur la
table à Bruxelles l'intègre
parce que une plateforme est en train
d'avancer sur le sujet nous devrions
faire une annonce bientôt qui n'est
malheureusement pas l'une des
plateformes principales encore enfin en
tout cas les selles qui ont le plus
d'abonnés
des médias qui
sont de plus en plus
qui perçoivent l'intérêt de démontrer
qu'ils sa strainait des obligations pour
trouver une place légitimement plus
grande dans l'espace public il y a un
enjeu majeur est-ce que ça se trouvera
sa conclusion dans le yorkan medefreedom
Act est-ce que ce sera plus tard
éventuellement dans la loi nationale
c'est qu'on impose aux plateformes
numériques d'amplifier
la visibilité des médias qui démontrent
leur fiabilité sur la base de leur
processus et sans jamais être sur les
contenus
il se peut que ça avance dès le yorkia
près de la moitié des États européens
qui sont favorables une partie du
Parlement y est favorable bref
c'est encore un combat qui peut jouer
aujourd'hui à Bruxelles mais peut-être
demain sur le plan national dans dans
une régulation nationale
si on n'arrive pas à remettre ce
principe
au coeur des algorithmes si on laisse
les algorithmes répondre d'abord à une
logique marchande ce qui est le cas de
TikTok alors on accepte que notre espace
public soit soumis à une logique
marchande et qui est pas simplement des
gens qui font des activités commerciales
et de toutes sortes qui jouent dans
l'espace public mais que ce soit
l'espace public lui-même que ce soit
dans cette logique donc là il y a un
combat majeur à mener sur ce point la
troisième chose c'est comment des
démocraties gèrent la globalisation de
l'espace de la formation et de la
communication et comment se pose d'une
certaine manière
l'action des limites des espaces publics
et est-ce qu'on peut trouver une voie
entre
une
j'oublie le terme à l'instant mais une
décomposition de l'espace international
de cet espace global
fragmentation je l'ai retrouvé revenant
à des espaces nationaux ce qui
sertraitables mais comment l'inverse on
est vite de se retrouver dans un espace
où la symétrie entre les dictatures et
les démocraties favorise les dictatures
et là on a formulé une proposition de
système de protection des espaces
informationnels démocratiques de
cadre de régulation permettant d'aller
dans le sens de la plus grande ouverture
mutuelle mais permettant aussi aux
démocraties de se défendre sur la base
d'un système de réciprocité intégrant
les principes universels de la liberté
d'expression la semaine dernière deux
commissions du Parlement européen ont
fait la recommandation de la mise en
place de systèmes la commission
ING un gérant étrangère et la Commission
[Musique]
à faire étrangères du Parlement européen
l'ont recommandé
et donc
là aussi il y a matière à avancer est-ce
que ce sera au niveau national au niveau
européen mais en tout cas c'est une
proposition que nous mettons sur la
table
un point final à cette intervention
la logique de l'organisation des espaces
publics c'est évidemment
de prévoir que ce qui fait exception à
liberté d'expression n'y est pas sa
place mais par ailleurs la construction
des espaces publics s'est construite
autour de l'idée que dès lors qu'on
n'avait en mesure de prouver qu'on
respectait des processus d'indépendance
éditoriale d'éthique de méthodologie etc
ça pouvait donner une plus grande place
au centre de l'espace public et donc je
crois que l'objectif des démocraties ne
doit pas être de tout traité par
l'exception à la liberté d'expression
mais en revanche de renforcer au coeur
de l'espace public et donc au coeur des
algorithmes évidemment quand j'étais
espace public à la fin je veux dire
algorithmes toutes les sources
d'information j'entends les médias
d'information quel que soit leur statut
et fiables qui en font la démonstration
ce qui aura pour effet incident mais
important
de renvoyer vers les marges tous ceux
qui ne respectent au sein aucun de ces
principes et qui sont
soit purement et ne dans l'opinion pure
ou
propageons des rumeurs des manipulations
de la propagande ou des propos voyant
des complots partout sachant que les
compos existent mais qu'il y en a sans
doute moins que de le croire certains
merci Monsieur le Secrétaire général je
propose que monsieur le rapporteur
prenne la parole et les collègues qui
souhaitent intervenir ce signal merci
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation et puis merci
beaucoup de nous avoir de votre
introduction et puis aussi de nous avoir
fait parvenir avant cette séance
un certain nombre
de propositions de votre part à certains
nombre de documents assez détaillés sur
les propositions que au fait
et donc vous avez repris une partie tout
à l'heure alors
ça ça m'amène à
plusieurs questions qui sont de nature
différente la première c'est
et vous en avez parlé
c'est pour faire vite le DS
mais essentiellement le DSA
vous avez parmi vos propositions je
pense que votre opinion c'est que le DSA
est une est un premier pas qui est
intéressant de la même façon que le rgpd
a été un premier pas qui a été ensuite
suivi dans d'autres pays que
des pays d'Europe
et le DSA est une étape supplémentaire
mais vous avez dit en même temps que ce
DSA
vous paraissait insuffisant et que il
fallait y ajouter un certain nombre de
propositions dont des exemples donc vous
avez donné des exemples
alors le problème on est directement
dans le cœur du sujet en France puisque
dans quelques semaines le Sénat comme
l'Assemblée nationale va être appelés à
voter sur une loi un projet de loi
présenté par le ministre du numérique
que nous auditions dans quelques jours
qui consiste schématiquement à
transposer le DSA
ce serait l'occasion pour nous
de suivre un certain nombre de vos
recommandations et de les proposer en
amendement à ce projet de loi mais il se
trouve que le procureur de la Cour de
justice européenne c'est dans la presse
aujourd'hui et notamment dans le journal
l'opinion que le procureur de la Cour de
justice
européenne vient de donner son avis sur
un litige qui oppose les plateformes les
principales plateformes je crois qu'il y
en a trois c'est Facebook Google et Tik
Tok
à la Commission européenne
et que ce procureur ça n'est pas le
jugement c'est la vie du procureur et le
jugement devrait être rendu sans doute
dans quelques semaines ou quelques mois
je n'en sais rien mais que le procureur
recommande estime que la transition du
DSA dans les différents dans les
différents droits européens ne saurait
aller au delà
des articles contenus dans le DSA c'est
à dire que ce qui est aujourd'hui sur le
transposition que nous pouvons faire en
France parce que sinon ce serait pas
conforme au cas où la commission
[Musique]
encore de juger européenne suivrait la
vie du procureur nous ne pourrons
absolument pas
proposer des
amendements qui iraient au delà du DSA
ce qui veut dire qu'en tout cas en
France et même dans l'ensemble des pays
européens les propositions que vous
faites dans ces conditions ont assez peu
de chances d'être retenu
peut-être est-il encore temps d'alerter
pour vous et comme pour nous d'alerter
les juges de la Cour de justice
européenne c'est sans doute trop tard
parce que la procédure est à est en
cours je pense plus quoi pas qu'on
puisse encore demander d'être audité
mais c'est pour moi un problème un
problème important
alors
le deuxième
sujet connexe c'est que
le DSA prévoit
ou plutôt oui le DSA vrai voix et les
négociations au sein de l'Union
européenne prévoit que les régulateurs
nationaux en France l'arcome et la CNIL
essentiellement vont être dépossédés de
leur pouvoir d'enquête et de sanctions
leur comme totalement et la CNIL pour
une bonne part de ces de ces activités
et que tout cela bien entendu ils
pourront toujours être saisis par des
plaignants ou par des gouvernements
mais que la
plainte sera désormais pour les 27 pays
de l'Union européenne transmises à la
dipcie irlandaise
qui sera le juge en dernier instant
juge qui devra évidemment proposer au 27
et c'est le cas d'ailleurs dans une
décision sur le site qui doit être prise
dans le courant de l'été juges qui sera
évidemment qui aura consulter les 27
régulateurs européens mais qui sera
s'ouvre et d'ailleurs on en a l'exemple
dès aujourd'hui sur une sur la décision
dont je vous parlais qui
[Musique]
a fait l'objet de remarque d'un certain
nombre de
régulateurs
que le déficit d'après mes informations
je n'ai pas une certitude semble ne pas
avoir choisi de suivre
alors moi ça me pose un problème
particulier parce que
le difficile irlandais
c'est quand même aujourd'hui
le régulateur qui a beaucoup de raisons
de montrer beaucoup plus de tolérance
par rapport à un certain nombre de
plateformes et notamment celle qui sont
installées en Irlande pour des raisons
fiscales assez évidentes c'est notamment
le cas de TikTok de Tik Tok qui conquis
aujourd'hui
à sa maison mère européenne en Irlande
et qui demain avec le projet Clover sera
encore
faire des investissements en Irlande qui
se montrant à des centaines de millions
de d'euros
[Musique]
en faisant cela nous les pays européens
et en ce qui nous concerne la France se
coupe
dans une très très grande mesure
pratiquement définitivement est
totalement d'une possibilité de
régulation sur ce qui se passe dans leur
propre vie alors sur le fond du dossier
moi je suis européen et je pense que ce
genre de sujet doivent se traiter à un
niveau européen mais je suis mais
l'ampleur des délégations et le fait
de les confier à un régulateur qui n'a
pas fait la preuve d'une très grande
fermeté dans des sujets qui sont parfois
où il y a un déséquilibre entre les
plateformes et les gouvernements et la
Commission européenne au bénéfice de ces
plateformes qui sont beaucoup plus
puissantes beaucoup plus qui ont
beaucoup plus de personnel
m'interroge et je voulais vous demander
ce que vous pensez de ces deux questions
mis ensemble
[Musique]
semble pour moi présenter un risque
important je voulais vous demander votre
avis à ce sujet
je répondrai en étant conscient que je
ne suis pas juriste que donc
mes réponses ne porteront pas sur le
droit stricto sensu
sur le second point
il semble évident enfin les deux
questions que vous posez sont
effectivement des questions extrêmement
inquiétantes
pourquoi
parce que sur le second point
je réfléchis en vous parlant mais il est
évident quand on avait quand on a vu
l'intensité du lobbying et la diversité
des méthodes de lobbying des plateformes
ne serait-ce qu'au moment de l'adoption
de la directive sur les copyrights sur
les droits voisins
on ne peut que s'inquiéter sur leur
capacité de lobbing après l'adoption de
la loi au moment de sa mise en œuvre
et que j'imagine que c'est un des
éléments que vous avez en tête lorsque
vous en parlez
que
il serait dangereux de mettre un tous
ces œufs dans le même panier
et a fortiori comme vous le disiez à
l'organe de régulation d'un pays
qui a démontré
combien ces intérêts économiques étaient
attachés aux intérêts des plateformes et
qui les alliés
et quel que soit l'indépendance affichée
des organes de régulation il y a
toujours lieu d'avoir une forme de
suspicion sur leur indépendance réelle
parlent pas de cet organe de régulation
que je ne connais pas mais réfléchissant
de manière un peu large il y a là un
danger
extrêmement
fort le second point
qui est sur votre premier point
pardon une réponse à votre premier point
je ne sais pas effectivement ce que sera
le jugement
j'espère que la régulation ne s'arrêtera
pas là nous ne sommes favorables à une
régulation je vais être très clair qui
il y a deux types de régulation il y a
la régulation de contenu et la
régulation de moyens
la régulation de contenu assez
légitimité mais elle doit être limitée
et on ne va pas
répondre à beaucoup de problèmes en
accroissant la régulation de contenu et
il y a eu des volontés en Europe de
donner voilà de
contraire de de l'espace numérique des
contenus
licites mais dangereux ça ce serait de
fait une attitude extrêmement dangereuse
que d'aller là-dedans mais en termes de
régulation de moyens il serait dommage
de se priver de régulation plus avancée
sachant que
le DSA qui laisse aux plateformes
apprécier le risque systémique qu'elle
pose elle-même ça revient un peu à
demander à Monsanto de dire si son
propre produit est dangereux
et
juste pour synthétiser l'ensemble on est
sur une question fondamentalement
démocratique je ne serai pas scandera la
cour de carlsr pour l'Allemagne qui est
plus stricte
que dans d'autres pays sur ces questions
mais il semble
que sur des questions
aussi importantes du point de vue
démocratique effectivement
aller loger cela dans un organe de
régulation d'un pays tiers
pouvant être soumis à des influences
fortes
est un jeu assez risqué
merci bien
alors une deuxième question qui qui fait
suite ce que vous avez expliqué d'avoir
cette introduction et que vous expliquez
également dans le
document régulation des plateformes
numériques et des réseaux sociaux
où vous dites expressément la
réglementation des plateformes
numériques suppose d'inventer un
troisième statut entre celui d'hébergeur
dénué de responsabilité et celui
d'éditeur doté d'une responsabilité et
d'une liberté éditoriale RSF propose que
les plateformes soient considérées c'est
ce que vous venez de répéter comme des
services d'intérêt général également
appelé public et utilities et soumise au
régime de responsabilité qui en découle
alors c'est une réflexion qui qui
rejoint l'un d'eux et qui peut-être va
plus loin que la nôtre est dans le cadre
des propositions elle est peut-être plus
intelligente que la nôtre puisque voilà
puisque c'est ce que j'allais dire le
Sénat a voté
après avoir discuté à une reprise en
commission de la culture dont était
présidente jusqu'à une adressante madame
Morin de Sailly le Sénat a voté un
amendement que j'avais proposé
qui expliquait qu'à partir du moment où
une plateforme organisée une curation
vous avez utilisé ce mot tout à l'heure
par algorithme un autre proposé pour
aider informatique il n'était plus un
simple hébergeur il avait une vocation
éditoriale par les algorithmes mais par
conséquent il devenait un éditeur il lui
avait emporter la responsabilité elle a
été votée à l'unanimité au Sénat contre
la vie du gouvernement à l'époque mais
elle n'est jamais n'a jamais été
présenté à l'Assemblée nationale donc
elle n'est pas un n'est pas en fonction
néanmoins la proposition que vous faites
est une proposition intermédiaire qui me
paraît intéressante parce qu'on y
réfléchissant bien il est il est vrai
que
ces plateformes sont tout de même dans
une situation d'intermédiaire entre les
deux statues et que vous ayez une une
solution
malheureusement le DSA a choisi sur et
notamment à la suite du hubbing
extrêmement fort des gafam et de
batx pour pour une partie
de ne pas retenir cette solution
[Musique]
voilà je voulais avoir votre sentiment
là-dessus est-ce que vous pensez que ce
que vous estimez que la solution
proposée par le DSA répond en tout ou en
partie à la solution que vous proposez
d'abord le dessin a posé un cadre
la question se pose maintenant de
l'utilisation de ce cadre il est assez
difficile de prévoir la mise en oeuvre
du DSA
sera-t-elle
très scrupuleuse les
[Musique]
personnes en charge de l'application du
DSA auront-elles accès à suffisamment de
données auront-elles les capacités de
statuer
quel sera l'intention et et la fermeté
de l'imposition des principes
démocratiques ça c'est difficile à
savoir mais moi je dirais pas tout à
fait que le DSA
a refusé d'entrer dans cette logique
j'ai peut-être que au contraire le DSA
est d'une forme d'engagement dans cette
logique de troisième statut même si
c'est pas précisé comme tel et que le
DSA ne maintient pas la logique
d'hébergeur ne dis pas que les
plateformes sont des médias pourquoi
nous sommes opposés nous croyons que
les plateformes numériques ne devraient
pas être considéré comme des éditeurs
parce que le principe d'un éditeur
c'est d'abord d'être un acteur dans le
cadre d'un pluralisme général
qui est responsable de ces contenus
évidemment responsables de statuer sur
le fait qu'il n'y ait pas de choses
illicite mais qui
a le droit dans l'organisation du
pluralisme de décider de ce qu'il y a
sur sa plateforme et que
faire de Mark Zuckerberg du patron de
Tik Tok ou d'autres l'équivalent d'un
éditeur ce serait leur dire vous avez
droit à une ligne éditoriale
vous pouvez décider de retirer ce qui
vous convient puisque vous êtes
l'équivalent d'un éditeur et ce serait
finalement leur conférer un pouvoir que
sans doute
vous n'avez pas envie de leur conférer
puisque ce sera un pouvoir
absolument fascinant à des échelles sans
commune mesure avec les médias dont il
convient de bien organiser le la
concentration
et d'arriver à des niveaux de
pertinentes concentration et donc
se pose d'ailleurs dans dans l'ensemble
et en ce moment c'est traité dans le cas
des discussions sur le York media
freedom Act
dans quelle mesure
même dans le cadre donc du la des
discussions de ce droit là les
plateformes sont-elles autorisées à
prendre des décisions y compris sur des
coups alors sur l'ensemble des contenus
des décisions de modération mais y
compris sur les contenus des médias
[Musique]
est-ce que c'est très potentiellement
extrêmement dangereux que des acteurs
aussi importants dotés d'un tel pouvoir
puisse
prendre des décisions qui relèvent de
décision éditoriales
nous croyons que comme les plateformes
numériques sont des bouts d'espace
public
précisément il faut leur donner des
formes de de neutralité par exemple sur
les questions politiques idéologiques
religieuses
une neutralité
vis-à-vis de leur propre intérêts
et
moi tous les jours en ce moment quand
j'ouvre mon Twitter je tombe sur un
tweet Delon musk
il semble que Twitter pousse ce tweet en
tout cas alors c'était pas le cas pour
l'un de mes collègues mais là il se
comporte clairement comme éditeur et
donc il faut des obligations de moyens
très fortes mais qui sont adaptées à ce
que sont les plateformes
c'est à dire pas à une équipe qui
produit un contenu pour un lectorat mais
bien un organisateur de notre espace
public
troisième question toujours dans
la même
préoccupation
et vous nous en avez parlé un peu mais
vous en parlez plus dans la note que
vous avez envoyé vous dites transparence
des algorithmes les exigences de
transparence doivent cibler les
fonctions essentielles de toutes les
plateformes dans l'écosystème de
l'information publique modération du
contenu classement du contenu ciblage du
contenu et renforcement de l'influence
sociale l'application de principe de
transparence et d'explicabilité
nécessaire dans la modération
automatisée donc algorithmique j'imagine
notamment les utilisateurs doivent être
informés des billets des algorithmes et
de leur modèle d'entraînement du taux de
faux positif et de faux négatif des
algorithmes ils doivent également avoir
accès aux données d'entraînement des
algorithmes les plateformes doivent être
tenues responsables des torts causés par
leur algorithme
est-ce que dans
ce que vous savez aujourd'hui du DSA les
propositions
satisfont à cette demande de votre part
je ne voudrais pas
on est encore loin loin nous il nous
semble qu'on est plus aujourd'hui ce qui
requis du dessin plus une transparence
sur des intentions
c'est un affichage plus qu'une
transparence qui est attendue des
plateformes
nous croyons que
[Musique]
dès lors que le code c'est la loi
la loi doit être transparente alors
est-ce qu'il y a des dispositifs à
inventer qui permettent d'avoir une
transparence qui soit pas à tout
requérant ou au grand public de toute
façon n'ira pas voir mais à des organes
de régulation qui pourront statuer en
étant eux-mêmes soumis à des formes de
[Musique]
à des secrets pour ne pas révéler sur la
place publique la transparence en tout
cas de notre point de vue il doit y
avoir une transparence la plus absolue
vis-à-vis d'institutions démocratiques
en charge de vérifier autrement ça
s'appelle pas la transparence
c'est une réponse tout à fait nette
qui trancherait si elle était appliquée
avec avec l'opacité actuelle de tous les
algorithmes en général mais en ce qui
concerne TikTok dans l'algorithme gérer
améliorer
développer en Chine est encore et sans
doute le paroxysme de ce qu'on peut
faire merci beaucoup
je voudrais vous demander
si je le retrouve
est-ce que vous avez
identifié en matière de de pratique non
déontologique est-ce que vous avez
identifié sur Tik Tok puisque notre
commission dans vous l'avez peut-être
remarqué sur d'autres et notamment sur
Facebook ou vous avez vous êtes
intervenu est-ce que vous avez
identifié sur le Tik Tok des pratiques
non déontologiques du type des
informations mes informations
censure ou comme beaucoup comme
plusieurs
comme plusieurs
employés ou responsables d'autres
plateformes
s'en sont plein énormément d'un vol de
données d'un vol de vidéo d'un vol de
documents
retransmis directement sur la plateforme
de Tik Tok sans avoir évidemment sans
contraste en paiement sans droit etc
nous n'avons pas lancé d'études sur le
sujet je suis incapable de vous répondre
susceptibles de devoir intervenir en
initie comme ça on pourrait revenir
tranquillement
dans le boulanger des questions de notre
rapporteur des questions tout à fait
pertinentes sur le dessin on a tous bien
conscience que c'est une étape mais que
celle-ci est forcément un peu frustrante
insuffisante
dans les rapports que nous avons fait
sur le DSA et le DMA on a cherché bien
sûr à amplifier ici au Sénat au sein de
notre commission des affaires
européennes cette législation qui nous
est proposé pour aller dans le sens de
la responsabilité
responsabilisation des des
plateformes ne croyez-vous pas en
réalité que on sera de toute façon
amenée à migrer vers un autre type de
teforme vertueux par son modèle
économique
qui revient questionner la publicité
ciblée et du coup la construction de
l'algorithme pour aller chercher
toujours plus de clics rémunérateur et
enfermé les utilisateurs dans des bulles
de certitudes des bulles de vérité ou
des des
façons de les comportements de
consommateurs est-ce que vous pensez
qu'un un modèle finalement d'abonnement
qui permettrait de se trouver dans un
espace public cette fois régulé
différemment d'un point de vue
économique serait viable selon vous ça
c'était ma première question ma deuxième
question porte sur
les journalistes vous avez évoqué les
journalistes
emprisonnés en Chine très contraint
est-ce que vous avez des témoignages
justement de la façon dont
comment dirais-je il s'inscrivent dans
cet espace numérique leur publication
est-ce qu'il y a des est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer concrètement
comment ça se traduit des censures de de
leurs articles voilà on a besoin d'en
savoir un petit peu plus pour comprendre
finalement comment la relation aux
plateformes et à Tik Tok peut ou ne peut
pas du tout se construire
alors votre question sur les plateformes
vertueuses
je crois que le principe de la loi c'est
qu'il peut y avoir des gens vertueux
mais
que le les institutions démocratiques
doivent s'assurer que les mal compris
votre question
à l'heure actuelle
aujourd'hui il a pas été inventé et
aujourd'hui les sociétés relevant du
capitalisme de surveillance décrit par
shoes of dans son livre sur l'âge de
capitalisme surveillance ont
la maîtrise elles ont aussi un avantage
c'est que non seulement
elles peuvent avoir une vision claire de
de ce que nous sommes et faisons mais en
plus elles peuvent prédire nos
comportements et que que ce capitalisme
de la prédiction un potentiel de de
manipulation globale qui aujourd'hui en
fait des
des sociétés dominantes et de ce
strictes sont d'autant plus dominantes
que
le stock de de d'informations accumulées
leur donne un tel avantage concurrentiel
qu'il est difficile à des nouveaux
entrants de se faire une place au soleil
mais une place sur le marché
[Musique]
le problème c'est enfin j'ai peut-être
ça mérite plus long que c'est vraiment
une très bonne question ça mérite plus
longue réflexion mais dès lors que le
le coeur même de la machine ou l'objet
de la société c'est d'organiser
l'information et que la société a besoin
d'en tirer des revenus
qu'elle tire des revenus de cette
organisation on peut se dire que ça
soumet
le modèle même à une logique marchande
par définition mais peut-être vous avez
des idées en tête et je vais réfléchir
et je serais ravi de poursuivre cette
réflexion
ce modèle n'a pas été trouvé et
on peut se
je crois que de toute façon pour qu'il
soit trouvé ou pour s'assurer que les
sociétés le respectent il faudra leur
poser des formes de principe
et que
qu'il surviennent spontanément ou pas il
y aura suffisamment de de
société commerciale technologique
utilisant des modèles
dont le modèle économique est dangereux
tout à l'heure je citais le l'incapacité
moi je suis sidéré par
la confiance qu'on a pu faire aux
plateformes sur la lutte contre la
désinformation
elles ont dit partout
ne nous régulez pas on s'en occupe
on voit ce qu'il en est quelques années
plus tard pourquoi parce que elles ont
introduit
elles ont organisé des actions qui
relevaient du du
blanchiment
elles ont alloué des Fonds des médias
pour faire du fact checking elles ont
monté des opérations mais tout ça
permettait de ne pas atteindre au cœur
du système et l'objet c'était surtout ne
touchez pas notre système on est prêt à
faire des chèques à droite à gauche
et à donner l'impression qu'on agit
et
dès qu'il s'agit d'aller tout au cœur du
système là elle refuse peut-être leurs
intérêts sont en jeu aujourd'hui elle
refuse il y a quelques jours encore
YouTube a annoncé que
YouTube ne s'attacherait plus à empêcher
la diffusion des contenus des
informations dans la perspective de
l'élection américaine
ces gens là jouent avec le feu et et
il me semble qu'aujourd'hui
les plus grands réseaux sociaux enfin
aucun d'entre eux n'a mis en place des
mesures systémiques et aucun d'entre eux
n'a dit je suis prêt à limiter les
dividendes pour mes actionnaires afin de
sauver la démocratie dans l'arbitrage
il y a même pas eu un déplacement de
curseur tout est du côté de l'avantage
économique
oui
approfondir le sujet des journalistes en
Chine voilà leur relation voilà
l'Internet au numérique aux plateformes
particulièrement à TikTok comment
concrètement ça se ça se passe cette
chanson extrêmement précise
là-dessus on pourra fournir les deux
rapports qu'on a publié
mais les
l'Internet chinois est un Internet ou
lorsque il y a une bulle d'expression
un peu libre elle est immédiatement
réprimée les choses disparaissent comme
à part entendement de la même manière
que l'économie chinoise est une un
théâtre d'ombre avec toujours le Parti
communiste chinois derrière
d'ailleurs je vous renvoie un livre qui
a été écrit par un ancien journaliste
enfin par journaliste britannique qui
s'appelait the party jeux de mots sur la
fête mais là c'était sur le Parti
communiste chinois et qui racontait
comment
il n'existait pas d'économie privée
chinoise
au fond tout le privé relevait du
finalement d'un contrôle d'État alors ça
ne permet pas d'affirmer sur le cas Tik
Tok et je veux pas inférer de de
généralités
mais
voilà je les ai tout à l'heure on est
j'imagine que c'est ce sur quoi ça quoi
votre commission est confronté c'est la
question de d'épreuve
s'agissant de de du contrôle de Pékin
mais encore une fois qui revient la
charge de la preuve et l'organisation du
système politique chinois de de
l'ensemble de de
l'espace de l'information chinoise est
un espace de contrôle
monsieur président se rapporteur nous
avons lors d'une audition compris que
Tik Tok financé certains grands
événements culturels comme le Festival
de Cannes le samedi j'aurais aimé que
vous donniez votre sentiment là-dessus
si vous pensez que grave gravissime que
on est un petit peu fou de faire ça et
vous avez porté plainte contre Tik Tok
est-ce qu'il y est votre facebook
donc ma question bah non je la retire
des dommages parce que on aurait
peut-être eu quelques réponses
sur
[Musique]
je vous appelle dans une forme de
subjectivité trop grande
je dirais la question que j'ai appris il
y a quelques jours à propos du stand au
salon du livre
qui d'ailleurs démontrait ce stand à la
fois une forme de soft power de TikTok
et en même temps
l'influence de ces recommandations y
compris en matière éditoriale et pour
faire vendre des livres
qui ne sont sans doute pas ceux que nous
lisons autour de cette table mais qu'on
a un impact qui peuvent avoir un
atteindre des audiences extrêmement
grandes
vu que ça n'est peut-être pas le point
central
mais ça fait partie des opérations de
lobbying comme les plateformes en fond
moi je dois dire qu'il y a un Reporters
sans frontières et il s'agissait pas de
Tik Tok il s'agissait de de
compagnies américaines mais lorsque j'ai
pris mes mes fonctions nous avions un
donateur et une grande diversité de
financement le seul qui avait qui
tentait de me tordre le bras était une
entreprise du numérique américaine
le seul qui essayait vraiment de nous
influencer à travers ces financements
je crois que il y aura une histoire à
écrire des opérations de lobbying et de
l'influence via la capacité financière
des sociétés technologiques est-ce que
vous venez d'évoquer fera peut-être
l'objet d'une partie de chapitre
avant de passer la parole endrigatelin
je vais me faire un peu l'avocat du
diable mais pour permettre justement de
Serrier quels sont les problèmes aigus
et ce finalement on est dans une espèce
d'entre-deux quelle est la différence de
nature entre ce que fait Tik Tok au
salon du livre et le
comment dire ce que fait dit toi selon
du livre ou personne n'est dupe ici du
fait que nous ne sommes pas dans les
années folles le nouveau
surréalisme etc pour un peu on a écouté
monsieur Garandeau l'autre jour
on était pas loin de cyclos de sauter
était encore là il ferait ses films en
format court sur TikTok
le ridicule ne tue pas mais ça rapporte
probablement beaucoup par ailleurs d'un
point de vue pécunier mais quelle est la
différence entre le partenariat Tik Tok
avec le Salon du livre et un public
reportage dans ce que ça de plus
classique et qui se fait dans la presse
alors le publier du reportage est
parfaitement répréhensible lorsqu'il se
passe
c'est d'ailleurs un terrain sur lequel
on commence
à aller je crois que ça fait une dizaine
il y a une dizaine de jours
on a
révélé l'existence de pratique dans la
revue des anciens Léna
qui comme un certain nombre de
médias
faisait appel pour le coup de manière
demandait
contre ré enfin proposait contre
rémunération de publier des contenus
relevant de la publicité et n'ayant pas
présenté comme tel je crois que c'est un
enjeu
majeur de nos sociétés que de conserver
la distinction entre les contenus
journalistiques et la publicité
il y a toujours eu des formes de
corruption
il y a des périodes où elles étaient
relativement maîtrisées et faibles là on
est entré dans une aire de la corruption
des contenus pourquoi parce que si on
peut demander aux plateformes numériques
de ne pas on peut réguler les publicités
dites politiques c'est à dire
subventionné sur les plateformes et dans
les plateformes on connaissances
qu'elles ont fait l'objet d'une
subvention d'un sponsoring d'un achat
en revanche ces plateformes numériques
ne savent pas dans quelles conditions
ont été produits les contenus en amont
de leur publication
et
c'est la raison pour laquelle on
parviendra jamais y compris par le droit
pénal à empêcher que ces pratiques aient
lieu le seul moyen c'est de donner des
formes davantage à ceux qui démontrent
que la formation n'y est pas encore
rompu et ça je vous rejoins
totalement malheureusement le Brand de
Fontaine et le Brand de Fontaine pas
toujours affiché comme tel
les contenus sponsorisés
il y a des plateformes qui existent où
on peut s'acheter des articles enfin
acheter des articles sur soi quand on a
une entreprise ou un individu c'est une
dérive
complète certains médias j'espère rares
sont accommode en considérant que c'est
le moyen de sauver leur modèle
économique je crois qu'il est notre
responsabilité de trouver un moyen que
l'écosystème de l'information soit
organisés de telle manière qu'on puisse
surveillance là et
d'éviter que la corruption de
l'information devienne admise mais ma
question vise vraiment à comprendre
comment ça marche d'un point de vue
déontologique enfin je dis ça comme
lecteur
lambda moi je croyais que du moment que
le lecteur était informé du fait que
c'était un public reportage c'était
admis pas comme ça que ça marche
des médias de statuts différents
certains médias d'information d'autres
qui sont juste des médias donc c'est la
spécialité des chaînes qui ne sont pas
des grandes chaînes mais dans c'est
devenu le modèle économique et où
on ne vous présente pas les contenus
comme étant des sponsorisé et ça
évidemment c'est une dérive
quand des magazines nationaux vous font
un focus sur une ville ou un département
particulier mais parce que par ailleurs
il trouve des annonceurs d'une manière
d'une autre commandée par les
collectivités pour que le truc se fasse
quoi bah si trouve s'il y a des
annonceurs intéressés je ne bois pas en
quoi c'est répréhensible si contenu
n'est pas sur l'annonceur ça c'est autre
chose en fait on sait tous que la
personne qui va être ou le département
qui je dis ça en plus j'ai aucune
arrière pensée pour comprendre que le
département la région ou que sais-je qui
est l'objet du reportage et bien content
de se retrouver en une même si c'est la
diffusion purement locale d'un magazine
national et va envoyer le
comment dire la régie publicitaire du
journal va lui indiquer qu'elles peuvent
être les entreprises susceptibles de
d'allonger quoi enfin
la logique enfin pour travailler dans un
magazine un hebdo qui pratiquait ça la
logique a été plutôt une logique
d'audience c'était que faire
un supplément sur telle ville
effectivement
de supplémentaires et donc qui dit vente
dit le cachant annonceur et peut-être
avec des formes de publicité plus
ciblées parce que relevant de la région
ça moi j'y vois rien de réponse sans
modifier la ligne éditoriale
reste indépendante non ce qui est ce qui
là est répréhensible c'est lorsque
une entité quelle que soit son statut
achète un contenu enfin une personne
physique ou morale le plus souvent une
personne morale achète un contenu qui
relève de la publicité qui n'est pas
présenté comme tel et ça on voit que
c'est quelque chose qui est en train de
se développer avec
qui n'est pas aujourd'hui je pense au
coeur du système mais qui se débloque
qui se développe notre y compris à la
faveur de la pression concurrentielle et
et ça je crois que du point de vue
démocratique c'est essentiel de
maintenir de trouver les moyens que la
fonction sociale qui aujourd'hui celle
du journaliste soit exercé
en évitant le plus possible toute forme
de corruption
et et ça ça doit être au cœur de la
réflexion sur
le journalisme et l'avenir de
informations c'est comment au-delà même
de des milliers d'informations mais on
s'assure dans le débat public dans les
communications en général qu'on a des
formes de tiers de confiance et c'est
sans doute aujourd'hui ce qui est censé
représenter le journal
faisons en sorte que les moyens
économiques soient suffisants et donc
l'organisation du marché pertinentes
pour que des acteurs puissent exercer ça
sans l'ombre d'un
tension enfin ou d'une sensibilité à la
corruption merci monsieur gatelin
oui merci monsieur le Président moi j'ai
une question tout à l'heure vous avez vu
ok le fait que les plateformes les
réseaux sociaux n'étaient pas des
éditeurs en même temps quand on regarde
ce qu'est TikTok prenons la version
chinoise do Yin il produit d'ailleurs
des programmes éducatifs qui sont
reconnus pour leur qualité c'est une
manière aussi d'éviter les critiques
contre l'alignation ou le temps trop
long passé alors bien sûr il y a des
limitations de temps utilisés mais le
système des influenceurs c'est quand
même très particulier parce que
finalement ce sont des gens qui
produisent
pour TiK ToK on te les convu des diffusé
par TikTok
contenu de l'audience qu'ils ont et
récemment il était fait état de certains
influenceurs qui avaient pris des
positions notamment aux États-Unis sur
la question 8 cours qui se sont
retrouvées non pas censurés mais avec
des audiences qui passaient de cent
mille à 200 000 à 30 personnes
c'est-à-dire que c'est une censure
mécanique qui fait que l'algorithme tout
d'un coup vous coupe des gens qui sont
vos habitués c'est tout à fait une
logique de sous-traitance rédactionnelle
de censure exercer sur les contenus
les contenus diffusés avec un élément
supplémentaire que j'ajoute à la
réflexion donc aux États-Unis
s'entend peut-être le vent du boulet Tik
Tok qui a développé nouveau
réseau social qui s'appelle lemon eight
peut-être un peu plus âgé style de vie
etc et procède au débouchage de ces
peaux de ses propres je dirais
influenceurs aux personnes à succès de
TikTok pour les emmener fournir des
contenus et éditorials les monnaie pour
moi c'est une logique totalement
d'éditeur enfin qui qui cache son nom
quand on fait produire d'ailleurs avec
une idée annoncée et c'est déjà en œuvre
de la part de Tik Tok de dire nos
créateurs maintenant vont être rémunérés
en fonction de l'audience qu'ils ont
donc quelque part
en s'apparente est quelque chose qui
n'est plus je dirais du citoyen to
citizen mais du business intermédiaire
transféré à travers des gens qui font
office ou mine de produire des contenus
et sont reconnus comme tel avec certains
statuts et voir certaines censures et
non pas simplement des échanges
horizontaux entre deux lycéens qui
racontent leur journée leurs amours on
est dans quand même une construction
quasi je vais pas dire rédactionnelles
mais éditoriales d'une équipe on choisit
on débauche ces influenceurs et c'est
eux qui font le maximum donc on est on
est quand même dans un statut moi je
trouve extrêmement novateur sur le plan
purement de la novation de contenu mais
extrêmement dangereux terriblement
hybride et qui peut aussi leurrer très
fortement le ré les gens qui les
écoutent c'est une chose de de faire un
placement de produit
discret c'est autre chose que
d'instituer des gens comme pratiquement
éditeurs de contenu avec des
élaborations de films parfois assez
sophistiqués et délivrer un message et
quand le message ne correspond pas à ce
qu'attend la plateforme TikTok PAF tu
perds ton audience donc qu'est-ce que ça
vous suggère comme réflexion mais
j'entends parfaitement votre réflexion
et c'est vrai que les plateformes font
tellement de choses différentes qu'on
peut enfin c'est Janus si on peut leur
trouver beaucoup de visages
de plus en plus les plateformes
numériques par exemple nous font sortir
des logiques classiques
ne serait-ce du pluralisme parce
qu'elles vont nous apporter une réponse
unique comment les démocraties traitent
la question de la réponse unique aucune
de nos régulations ne répond à cette
question
si nous prétendons nous pensons que
l'idée d'en faire des éditeurs est une
mauvaise idée même pour envoyer à la
question sur les wiggours que vous
évoquez c'est que un éditeur a le droit
de ne pas parler des Ouigours un éditeur
n'importe quel éditeur de presse en
France peut décider que on s'intéresse
pas à ça
je pense pas que vous ayez envie de ça
pour les plateformes est-ce qu'on
oui mais précisément il faut l'empêcher
enfin ce serait curieux de
d'entériner par la régulation quelque
chose que justement on va empêcher
quand je parlais tout à l'heure de
d'obligation de neutralité politique
idéologique religieuse vis-à-vis de leur
propre intérêts c'est qu'il y a des
choses sur lesquelles précisément on ne
veut pas qu'elles aient leurs mots à
dire
alors si vous leur donnez le statut
d'éditeur au-dessus de la loi du 180
Mark Zuckerberg Elon Musk les patrons de
pardon de Tik Tok alors donnerez le
pouvoir de décider
ça c'est conforme à la liberté
d'expression mais j'en veux pas et donc
elles pourront orienter pour
pour un seul pays pour des dizaines de
millions de personnes
pour l'ensemble de l'humanité je crois
que c'est un milliard 7 pour c'est ça
pour un Tik Tok les contenus
il faut surtout pas leur laisser ce
pouvoir là donc
au contraire il faut leur donner
il faut les empêcher de prendre des
décisions à caractère politique
et si sont pas éditeurs je j'entends
bien quelle responsabilité ils ont par
rapport au contenu j'ai travaillé dans
un grand quotidien pendant quelques
années je sais ce que c'est d'être
responsable éditorial et de se retrouver
en justice de voir en décompte
c'est-à-dire je suis d'accord je
comprends la logique mais pour revenir
dans cette pièce même samedi dernier on
faisait un coloc sur la situation au
Cambodge qu'en représentant de RSF votre
directeur local et il y avait énormément
de gens de la communauté cambodgienne où
les médias sont censurés et les gens de
la communauté cambodgienne
s'offusquaient d'entendre dire de la
part de Daniel Bastard que facebook
n'était pas un média ils disent mais
c'est notre média c'est comme ça qu'on
communique c'est le seul moyen où on a
de l'information par rapport aux médias
officiels qui sont censurés je comprends
bien la logique intellectuelle mais
c'est inaudible par rapport aux citoyens
moyens mais Facebook que ce soit aux
Philippines au Cambodge ou j'ai
découvert plus récemment en
Ukraine en Ukraine les gens s'envoient
pas il y a beaucoup de gens ils
s'envoient pas de mails alors il y a
l'information passe telegram et les
échanges de mail c'est sur facebook
beaucoup y compris
des proches conseillers deuxième inscrit
donc on peut à un moment donné toujours
leur trouver quelque chose qui
s'apparente à l'édition mais c'est
tellement plus plus vaste ce qu'elles
font vous voyez tout à l'heure vous
parliez de de la publicité enfin de des
influenceurs mais au fond c'est des
formes de publicité plus ou moins
déguisées les influenceurs
dans la régulation des médias
aujourd'hui si vous êtes une chaîne de
télévision
et je ne compare pas les plateformes aux
chaînes de télévision mais juste pour
parler de la régulation des médias
aujourd'hui vous n'est pas le droit de
vous pouvez pas
faire que la publicité
occupe 90% des antennes
que on ne sache pas d'ailleurs si c'est
de la publicité ou pas de la publicité
ou du contenu journalistique il y a des
obligations
qui font l'objet des conventions un
programme de Téléshopping qui est dure
une heure ça respecte pas les logiques
d'insertion publicitaire
et
un exemple qui évidemment mais
quand même il y a une forme de
d'organisation de de du flux qui arrive
au public la question c'est ce qu'on est
capable de travailler sur l'organisation
du flux qui aujourd'hui nous arrive pour
les plateformes qui influent plus
compliqué
plus massif
et où elles ont un pouvoir beaucoup plus
grand et et je crois que ce sera
compliqué pour le pour le politique pour
pour vous
législateur parce que évidemment une
partie du public à mon câblement dira on
veut contrôler l'information on veut
m'empêcher de regarder ce que j'ai envie
de regarder moi je veux regarder du
Téléshopping toute la journée ou de la
publicité des spots publicitaires toute
la journée ou même des contenus qui
n'apparaissent pas comme publicité mais
qui en fait j'ai envie c'est mon droit
mais de fait ce qui s'est passé si on a
eu des espaces démocratiques c'est qu'on
a imposé des obligations
et et même si des gens n'ont envie que
de voir de voir que des contenus droits
tout de que des contenus de gauche on a
dit au réseau de distribution de la
presse tu n'as pas le droit à faire et
donc est-ce qu'on accepterait
aujourd'hui
que le réseau de distribution de la
presse depuis le distributeur jusqu'au
vendeur puisse faire des choix comme
Tic-Toc le fait sur les Wiggs non
mais donc Tik Tok c'est à la fois
vous le disiez aujourd'hui d'une
certaine manière le recruteur de
l'influenceur et ce qui fait travailler
mais c'est aussi le réseau de
distribution c'est c'est l'organisateur
de tout ça et c'est un organisateur
voilà qui
où il est légitime que
les institutions démocratiques imposent
des principes à l'organisation du flux
sans jamais entrer dans le contenu
lui-même enfin le contenu
c'est en restant dans une
philosophie politique libérale
nul n'est détenteur de la vérité la
question c'est de favoriser l'intégrité
l'honnêteté certains types de processus
après
chacun peut aller chercher la vérité par
ses moyens
si je fais une dernière question vous
avez évoqué le texte en préparation sur
la liberté des médias par la commission
il se trouve que avec Catherine Morin de
saillie on a produit
en tous les cas un pré rapport et on
entend bien faire un rapport complet
est-ce que vous pensez que une autorité
comme narcome est en mesure de régulier
à la fois les médias audiovisuels
numériques et presse écrite moi c'est
quand même quelque chose qui qui me
choque parce que la régulation de la
presse écrite on peut avoir des critères
de nature journalistique et les
indicateurs que vous tâchez de monter de
recréer pour la qualité journalistique
c'est une chose mais on peut pas
demander par exemple au quotidien
d'avoir la même logique de pluralisme
puisque c'est l'ensemble de l'écosystème
qui fait le pluralisme de la presse
écrite c'est pas la même chose en radio
télévision d'adélogique beaucoup plus
monopolistique on parle du fait que le
média radio est peut-être selon pays
théorique qui date des années 30-40 plus
influents et plus impactant que les
autres quid des réseaux sociaux et moi
ce qui m'inquiète toujours c'est dans
les instruments de régulation c'est très
bien de confier à des organismes y
compris comme l'équivalent de la CNIL
irlandaise des mastodontes mais la
réalité quid des moyens effectifs pour
assurer cette régulation si je confie à
la boutique du coin la capacité ou le
devoir de distribuer l'équivalent de
quatre supermarchés elle en aura le
droit mais elle sera pas le faire et ça
c'est une des autres inquiétudes que
j'ai dans dans le cadre bien évident
bien évidemment important que l'Union
européenne se dotent d'instruments qui
lui manquait singulièrement d'État de
droit et de protection de la liberté de
la presse mais je me demande si on n'est
pas dans la catatoire du droit sans les
moyens et la logique qui est propre à
chacun des médias est-ce que ça se
régule pareil la télévision en gros la
presse écrite et puis les réseaux
sociaux
alors plusieurs niveaux de réponse
d'abord je crois que
le système de régulation en découpage
par secteur presse écrite télé ça en
partie vieilli
qu'il y a des convergences entre les
médias que la télé est allée vers le
texte la presse écrite voudrait aller
vers la vidéo avec d'ailleurs des effets
de bord assez importants c'est-à-dire
que le fait qu'aujourd'hui pour être un
type de presse écrite vous devez pas
faire beaucoup de vidéos
alors même que c'est la vidéo
aujourd'hui qui mène l'audience
ça veut dire que votre site
si vous voulez garder une logique de
presse écrite votre site ne va pas vers
ce qui fait l'objet de la demande la
plus forte donc est-ce que on est quand
même dans un moment et désintermédiation
et d'explosion de ce système de
distinction des types de médias et c'est
notre régulation elle repose sur une
logique qui est en train de disparaître
et ça sans doute il faudra la faire
évoluer cet angle de je vous rejoins
totalement sur la question des moyens en
ce moment lovecom qui est l'équivalent
de l'art comme britannique est en train
de recruter 300 personnes je sais pas si
j'étais il y a quelques il y a trois
mois je crois ils étaient en train de
recruter 300 personnes sans avoir encore
les compétences par le Parlement
britannique mais pour se préparer à
traiter de ces questions
je pense que ce point de vue là
aujourd'hui la France
ne met pas les mêmes moyens à
disposition
donc qui faille un organe de régulation
qui a une vue quand même relativement
large
mais qui dans ce cas-là doit être un
organe de régulation assez fort parce
que
face à ces grands fauves numériques il
faut avoir une capacité forte et et
aujourd'hui
il faut avoir une capacité oui face à
Tik Tok Google Facebook et les autres
comme il le faudrait aujourd'hui face à
des acteurs en télévision qui méprisent
les principes démocratiques et notamment
la question du pluralisme interne qui
est le principe de régulation de l'eau
du viol par rapport pluralisme externes
pour la presse écrite je fais évidemment
en référence au dossier Bolloré
et et où déjà la loi impose à l'arcom de
mettre en oeuvre trois principes
honnêteté de l'information de
l'information et indépendance
et de notre point de vue l'arcome ne
s'attache pas assez à donner du contenu
à ces trois principes et à les imposer
et et
au nom d'ailleurs d'une d'une logique ou
d'une vision qui consiste à dire au fond
le champ de la communication c'est un
grand champ où
l'important c'est que
tout le monde puisse s'exprimer
également et chacun trouvera la vérité
en regardant l'ensemble
ce qui nous semble pas être pertinent du
point de vue de l'organisation d'un
système médiatique donc
[Musique]
en tout cas avoir des organes de
régulation trop sectorisés et les uns à
côté des autres nous sommes pas
un bon moyen de répondre à des questions
aujourd'hui qui sont vraiment très
vastes la deuxième chose c'est qu'il
nous semble nécessairement que la
régulation que
la législation ne permettra jamais de
suivre des évolutions et donc il faut
que déléguer à des organes indépendants
d'ailleurs le DSA de ce point de la pose
en partie question vu les pouvoirs de la
Commission européenne elle-même mais
délicat des organes indépendants le fait
un moment de pouvoir éditer des règles
au fil de l'eau sans attendre la
prochaine législation dans 20 ans
et d'ailleurs ça renvoie la question que
vous aviez
pardon
contre les ces organes indépendants au
Royaume-Uni contrôler il y a toujours
une charte royale tous les 10 ans et
c'est le Parlement qui mène le bal c'est
pas l'autorité indépendante qui
s'auto-évalue c'est quand même une
différence dans la conception du
contrôle démocratique
y a-t-il d'autres questions
y a-t-il quelque chose que vous auriez
souhaité porter notre connaissance non
je vous remercie à vous mais c'est nous
qui vous remercions beaucoup pour vos
éclairages sur ces questions de principe
merci beaucoup merci bonne soirée